[Musique]
j'ai monté de la barbe et la toute
puissance
il ya un conçoit de moitié de la société
ces deux moitiés pourtant dont 3
d'égalité l'une des moitiés suprême et
l'autre subalternes l'unfa tout est
soumise à l'autre et gouverne tout ça
c'est très joli mais ça va changer une
loi va ouvrir une brèche dans notre
vieux code civil et le bénéficiaire en
sera la femme et l'ins pauvre homme la
femme qui verra augmenter ses droits
mais aussi attention d'un de ses
responsabilités je m'explique le régime
des époux marié sans contrat sera celui
de la communauté réduite aux actes
la femme aura son mot à dire dans la
gestion des biens
[Musique]
chantez vous sent responsable de ses
dettes monsieur bois
[Musique]
oui madame est trop belle
ouais
ils gardent pour eux le produit d
héritage il s'agisse de biens mobiliers
immobiliers
elle pourrait opposer son veto à
certaines des opérations projetées par
le marbre
en cas de divorce c'est les immeubles
seront partagés les temps commun le
produit du travail acquis autour du
mariage
[Musique]